it's my first time back home on the
stage after giving birth I'm creating my
own homecoming and it's hard there was a
I thought you know I'll never be the
same I'd never be the same
physically my strength and endurance
would never be the same
Beyonce's Netflix documentary homecoming
dropped at midnight on a Wednesday did
you watch it because we didn't stay up
but we definitely got up early to watch
it woke up that were a little tired yeah
this is a gorgeous more than 2 hour long
film and it's also an intimate in-depth
look at the emotional road that led to
Beyonce's 2018 Coachella performance
which was epic so we're gonna break down
the biggest takeaways starting with her
pregnancy I mean when she was giving
birth to twins Sir Andrew mean it wasn't
exactly flawless no pun intended but she
gave birth to the twins on June 13 2017
and she really opened up in this
documentary about all the things she was
going through that we had no idea check
it out
I was supposed to do Coachella the year
prior
but
[Music]
I got pregnant unexpectedly my body went
through more than I knew we could I had
an extremely difficult pregnancy I had
high blood pressure I develop toxemia
preeclampsia and in the womb one of my
baby's heartbeat a few time that's scary
stuff she also revealed she was 218
pounds when she gave birth to the twins
thus beginning her insane diet workout
comeback in preparation for Bates Ella
here's what she was doing sixty-five
days before her performance its intense
guys no sugar no dairy no meat no fish
no alcohol hungry I don't what was she
eating them like I don't know spinach
like but she also opened up about why
Coachella was so important to her
because this is really a history-making
performance that happened in April 2018
it was important to me that everyone
that had never seen themselves
represented I felt like they were on
that stage with us as a black woman I
used to feel like the world wanted me to
stay in my little box and black women
often feel underestimated it was more
important that I brought our culture to
culture that we also really got to see a
side of jay-z in this documentary we
hadn't seen before and their little like
love connection it's so sweet yeah
because I feel like last time we saw
them with a lemonade they were like we
kind of saw them breaking up and coming
back together kind of thing and this is
just like their intimate adorable life
and at one point she facetimes him
all right to Pat's chair we all see uh
7-year old Blue Ivy I think she was six
at the time of the documentary but she's
taken after her parents she was caught
performing a verse from lift every voice
and sing and them girls up pipes
[Applause]
it feels good I have a feeling that
homecoming is all anyone's gonna be
talking about today especially because
Beyonce did what Beyonce does best and
she dropped a previously unannounced
alive album version of the concert I
mean when does this woman sleep honestly
when does she sleep that was my biggest
takeaway from the documentaries when
does she sleep she's the hardest working
woman in the entire world truth of
course will be here to keep you up to
date on all things mrs. Carter so be
sure to keep it locked on et until next
time I'm Holly Stevens I'm ash Carlton
bye for now
[Music]